[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Sunday night saquon Barkley and the
Giants battle my commanders in the NFC
East Showdown Sunday 7 Eastern on NBC
and peacock we have a trio of games
tomorrow don't sleep on those games and
one of the games will be the Cleveland
Browns and the Baltimore Ravens Rich
Eisen will be on the call NFL Network
he'll be there with Kurt Warner Steve
weish Stacy Dales that's at 4 30 Eastern
on NFL Network
what are your plans in Cleveland right
now what do you got coming up this is
how we do it Dan
um you know we're just sitting here
waiting to talk to the Ravens later
today okay
um just uh I've got my prep work I've
rest my rested my laptop on my prep work
right now okay I've literally taken time
out of my prep work so I could make sure
we have this conversation Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame on the agenda today no I'm
I'm here to work Dan I'm here to work
this is a working trip I'm not gonna hmm
I'm not gonna do anything other than
focus on the task at hand you're
professional yeah thank you lead pipe
wielding red pipe wielding you are
perfect let's guess since Rich doesn't
have time to go to the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame rich rich eisen's favorite
band all the time yes Todd I'm going to
start with you the Eagles all right
Seton O'Connor
I'm gonna say Coldplay Coldplay Marvin
the Smith System uh Paulie
I'm trying to guess Rich's age
I'm gonna go safe pick and go YouTube
you too okay
um I'm more of an individual uh first of
all not to not to pick nits but it's
just Eagles uh
the eagles look at any of their album
covers
like the old Sky Dome
just it's just and it's not Bronx it's
the Bronx I'm sorry that's just
something and it's not the NFL Network
it's NFL Network and the Golf Channel
it's Golf Channel that's it yeah it said
you got to know when there's a the oh
you gotta know when there's not or in
the case of Ohio State since I am in the
states
it's not the it's the it's difficult to
try and keep track but if anyone was
closest enough I'm gonna say here hey
here's my guess okay
Billy Joel that's it I'm from Staten
Island
I'm from Staten Island and you love
Billy Joe you know how I messed that up
I'm from Staten Island how could I not
my case Billy Joel born in Brooklyn
raised in Staten Island that's of course
uh but Coldplay if there was a band
Seton was close Okay Coldplay hey fair
enough I'm looking at the over under
it's 38 points for the Ravens and the
Browns
I don't know what you're talking about
Dan this is NFL Network uh we just only
have we're getting close this is
entertainment purposes only that that
information is now only on the graphics
remember remember when Berman would do
his two-minute drill and he would do or
his schwamy picks it'd take five minutes
to do the two minute drill the six and a
half minute drill
um they would always be like that arrow
that carrot that was next to a team even
if that wasn't the team that Chris was
predicting to win
NFL Network
NFL Network now has the information on
the bottom line we're working our way up
from the bottom of the screen it's on
that scroll it will say minus three
minus two and a half o slash U on our
graphic we're not there yet so I I am
not fully where all I know is that Tyler
Huntley it looks like he's gonna start
this game okay and um DeSean Watson
um has only one offensive touchdown to
his credit since returning so you know
uh one would think that this game would
be points challenged I mean Mark Andrews
hasn't scored a touchdown in a month and
a half for him so I I don't I don't know
if that's what you're asking do you get
to have access to DeSean Watson yeah
well there was a Cleveland Browns team
zoom with the crew yesterday uh I was
um on my show and traveling so I wasn't
part of that I do have access to it and
that's part of my prep work today but
yes there was access to him I did not
speak with him yet though the game will
be on NFL Network tomorrow at 4 30
Eastern Browns and the Ravens
give me the scenarios here that play out
for Brock Purdy and the 49ers and what
they mean for next year
for Brockwell the Niners uh it really
depends I guess the the scenario is he's
going to host uh he's going to play a
playoff game at home
um and right now that
um game would be against if I use the
phrase properly from what I heard before
your commanders Dan yeah
um or the Giants or the team we just saw
them beat last night or the Lions
um that that's basically it you know
those are the teams that they're gonna
face I don't think anybody from the NFC
South is going to put it together to put
a significant enough to put two teams uh
from that division in so one would think
that's the so-called winnable game it's
entirely possible that they do get up to
the two seed in time and and then have
the Vikings come to them or they go to
the Vikings
you know that that's possibly it uh
unless there's a shock
um at the bottom of the um somebody
shocks the Vikings and then suddenly the
Cowboys stroll into their building but
it's most likely going to be their
building so he's got one if not maybe
two home games in the playoffs in front
of him and the way that defense is
playing and the throws that he's making
even the third down throw late last
night that he made to ayuki hit him in
the hands and Ayu dropped it I mean he
is really locked in in terms of last
year next year it really depends on how
deep he goes and and how much the locker
room loves him and Shanahan's gonna have
to make that decision you just saw the
Jets do what they did to their second
overall pick uh chosen in front of Trey
Lance I I think if you have a coach and
a GM that can survive an ownership group
or person looking at them saying boy did
you blow that draft choice we're we're
going to get out all upset about it
that's not San Francisco so they could
do whatever the hell they want it seems
yeah it felt like if Jimmy G got that
team to the NFC title game of the Super
Bowl they would be bringing him back
well now if Brock Purdy can do the same
thing there's no need to bring Jimmy G
back but then you're gonna have a couple
of 22 year olds rock pretty turns 23.
but that to me is an I guess it's a good
problem to have but I wonder can Brock
Purdy win this job
moving forward I think so it really also
like like I said it depends on what the
locker room
um scene is and that's a again the only
analogy I can make and even though you
know the Niners can win the Super Bowl
this year and it doesn't appear that the
Jets can put something together it's
clear that Mike White has captured that
locker room it's clear that they love
him and so this is part of the the
decision making that you need to to go
through and I I think Purdy can not only
win the Super Bowl this year but the job
next year I mean why not it's it's a a
win now league and then down the road
you have to take in the the
consideration of hot seats and internal
politics and it doesn't appear the
Niners have that help me understand the
Micah Parsons bulletin board material
with uh Jalen hurts and the Eagles he's
with Von Miller and yeah on the Von cast
yeah the Von case calls it the Von cast
yes um that's what he calls it did you
did did I miss bulletin board material
here
that he he wouldn't allow that it's
Jalen hurts that's taking this team and
putting it in a different level that
it's the system
um he called him assistant quarterback
is what he basically called him and then
um you know uh
I I I I I think you know this is
definitely something that the Eagles
will just internalize and use in the
next week and a half
um right now I I don't think it really
means very much but this is all we're
going to be talking about next week
leading up to to this game is can the
Philadelphia Eagles close the door on
the Cowboys and the division or will
that still be an open question and
something that we can think about going
into January when they play their
playoff games I didn't I didn't think he
marginalized Jalen hurts I think he he
he complimented him he talked about it
but he said look this is it's it's about
22 guys and I'm a defensive guy we're
not given credit to the Eagles defense
there and I I mean I know system
quarterback firsthand calling Alex Smith
the system quarterback and I don't I
don't think he's over it yet with me but
I think what I mean Jalen hurts is his
own system
I I just didn't you know I'm I I didn't
see it's because it's the Cowboys
and it's Micah Parsons saying it
therefore it felt like it was going to
be illuminated a little bit more than
somebody else I I I I think so but Jalen
hurts has the second most
rushes in the NFL for first downs the
second most
number of times he has touched the
football and created a first down for
his team and he leads the league in
passer rating
he's an MVP and you don't sit around and
say that well the MVP is really the MVP
because he's part of the most valuable
system I mean that's that's where you
you have the needle rip off the Record a
little bit here I mean where the eye
test also shows you what's going on in
Philadelphia and for him like if he was
saying playing Mahomes he wouldn't say
that or Alan he wouldn't say that he
wouldn't say that even about Borough
right now you know this is this is also
a guy who as we know how he was born
into the league how he went through his
time at Alabama and the conversation
about him always was that he had to give
way to Tua or he was just a one-year
stop Gap from Kyler Murray to Lincoln
Riley's next guide Oklahoma that he
always the problem with him is his
ceiling wasn't high enough he would
always hit his head on the ceiling and
now he's ripped the roof off of
Philadelphia oh I think that
yeah I hope he wins the MVP uh I think
it'd be a great story there but I I just
I I was listening to and trying to put
it in context it didn't sound as
inflammatory as no you know I get it
yeah he didn't come out say the guy
stinks the biggest storyline of the NFL
is not about the game this weekend it's
about a game the following weekend I
didn't know I didn't think it warranted
that but
that's just me you know being so are you
I thought I had the game of you what if
I called my my game America's game of
the week just to just to do what do you
think well would you say that who
decides what is America's game of the
week would you call it the
no the it's Ohio okay it's the yeah I'm
trying to be respectful here I'm trying
to be respectful with my team being how
about the team and college football
playoffs the North America game of the
week
sure absolutely yeah
my game day morning's going against the
World Cup final I might as well just
make it completely International say
it's the world's game of the week well
that's where Fox was trying you know
because football night in America yeah
and then Fox wanted to compete with them
and then come up with a you know
America's game uh or whatever but it's
not it's not even that Fox's only game
when they call it America's game what if
you're on another crew and you're like
it's going on what do you mean I don't
get too caught up in it but uh yeah you
know well as you know I'm a guy who
always notices who's got the shoulder on
me and the group PR photos like I'm I
need to maybe get out of my own skull
Dan uh yes Paulie Dan uh rich is a
lifelong Jets fan is that correct that's
correct sir breaking news uh Jets
doctors will not clear Mike White for
contact before Sunday's game versus
Detroit hence Zach Wilson will start
against the Lions back to you okay
wow is that so huh they won't clear him
for uh for contact yeah well I guess
this is it this is Zach Wilson's time
this is it
this is honest I mean this what else can
I say other than the fact that the Jets
fans can't have nice things okay let me
talk to the Brennan Williams I mean I'm
sorry go ahead let me talk to the Jets
fan Rich Eisen here hey you know what
Zach Wilson is going to start this
weekend against the Lions Rich this this
guy this guy
this guy
that guy that guy that guy huh you got
to put a reset on this guy well it's
time to unset the reset huh we'll see
what happens against
um against a lot by the way uh the Lions
should should win this game they're
going up against the backup Jets
quarterback right
I mean yeah I don't know what to say
other than the fact that this hey look
the kid was told to get a reset uh they
put him up to number two for a reason
and now it's time you saw how um Mike
White has been able to
um find
um Garrett Wilson to the point where
Garrett Wilson's being talked about the
offensive Rookie of the Year going into
this week and then you've got
um uh Elijah Moore proof of life I mean
like when when Elijah Moore was uh uh
playing with Zach Wilson proof of life
he had to hold up a newspaper to make
sure it was that day you know so we'll
see have fun have fun in Cleveland I
will I will I'm looking forward to
seeing this large Elf on the field I'm
I'm I I've only talked about it I will
be there and Kurt Warner is yet to
confirm uh origin eye that he's wearing
that silver puffy jacket so um these are
many different ways and reasons to tune
in I want to know what's the jacket that
he turned down when he put on the silver
puffy package the one who's like yeah
that's too audacious I can't do that
I can't do that get out walk around a
little bit in uh in downtown Cleveland
okay I will do it all right thanks man
thank you buddy that's uh Rich Eisen
part of not the NFL Network it's NFL
Network and they'll bring you Browns
Ravens 4 30 Eastern tomorrow